[Music]
now earlier today 2024 Republican
presidential candidate Senator Tim Scott
he joined the ladies of that
hard-hitting ABC News show The View and
finally delivered some much needed truth
to the show's far left host take a look
you have indicated that you don't
believe in systemic racism what is your
definition of systemic racism let me ask
answer the question that you've answered
or does it even exist in your mind let
me answer the question this way one of
the things I think about and one of the
reasons why I'm on the show is because
of the comments that were made frankly
on this show that the only way for a
young African-American kid to be
successful in this country is to be the
exception and not the role that is a
dangerous offensive disgusting message
to send to our young people today that
the only way to succeed is by being the
exception I'm going to suggest the fact
of the matter is that progress in
America is palpable it could be measured
in Generations I look back at the fact
that my grandfather born in 1921 in
Sally South Carolina when he was on a on
a sidewalk a white person was coming he
had to step off and not make eye contact
that man believed then with some doubt
now and the goodness of America because
he believed that having faith in God
faith in them self and faith in what the
future could hold for his kids would
unleash opportunities in ways that you
you cannot imagine one of the reasons
why I took the funding for hbcus to the
highest level in the history of the
country and then I helped make it
permanent is because I believe that
education is the closest thing to Magic
in America so I'm about making sure that
our kids have as many opportunities to
succeed as possible
oh now notably absent from today's panel
was joyless Behar who came under Fire
for her previous comments accusing Scott
of not understanding racism remember
these comments
and he's one of these guys who you know
he's like Clarence Thomas black
Republican who believes in pulling
himself by your bootstraps rather than
to me understanding the systemic racism
that African Americans face in this
country and other minorities he doesn't
get it neither does uh Clarence right
and that's why they're Republicans
all right South Carolina Senator
presidential candidate Tim Scott is with
us with more about today's appearance
don't you like being lectured by a a
white liberal about what it's like to be
um to have an African-American
experience in America
um I've read your book I've read
Clarence Thomas's book I know your life
story I know clarence's life story uh
neither one of you had it easy in the
early part of your lives at all
plastic spoons not Silver Spoons but
more importantly Sean you hit the nail
on the head can you imagine an extreme
liberal elitist telling me how to be a
black man in America when she's a white
lady who dresses up in black face I
can't believe the hypocrisy that comes
out of that show sometimes it is the
height of hypocrisy to suggest that I'm
the exception when in fact their policy
positions is a radical left creates a
sorry a rule that simply says that in
order for us to be successful you have
to go to a failing school you have to
stay in your place you can't go up as
high as you possibly can the latter you
have to actually stay at the bottom
literally they're suggesting that the
rule that they want keeps poor kids in
failing schools keeps minorities at the
bottom of the ladder and then they
remove the rungs of the ladder to climb
we are a meritocracy your talent your
character your Grit take you as high is
you're willing to climb but according to
their policies they take the first three
rungs of the latter out I got to give
credit to Whoopi Goldberg who rightly I
thought chastised the audience when they
started to boo and she said no we're
going to let Senator Scott speak because
they did attack you when you weren't
there and I think you had every right to
do that look I I used to do that show
it's not worthwhile to do that show for
me but what I liked about today's
today's edition is is they were
listening to you whether they wanted to
or not your message came through loud
and clear and I think it's a message
that frankly Senator transcends even
race in as much as you know this should
be the country with the latter to
success and and and not we're not a
nation of victims and We're a nation of
people that can do great things
regardless of how difficult our
circumstances were when we grew up or
how hard our lives have been lots of the
things we Face absolutely so one of the
things that you and I have in common is
a very blue collar everyday American
background you and I both had to figure
out how to succeed eat in life but the
conditions of America make it possible
for the working class person to come to
the heights of being in TV you can look
at me and say a kid growing up in a
single parent household mired in poverty
candy one day be a congressman or
Senator or business owner the answer is
yes yes yes why because America
continues to evolve in the right
direction we continue to call upon our
met our better angels we are a more
perfect union today than we were
yesterday or last year or last decade we
have to believe in the future of this
country and then lean into that future
and make it what it should be spend more
time in the windshield and less time in
the rear view mirror
yeah let's talk a little bit about your
your run for president here
um I knew it was I had interviewed you
and you said you were thinking about it
um you've got a pretty formidable field
that you're going up against talk about
the decision leading up to you deciding
to make this run and what will be
different about your campaign and your
view well thank you Sean one of the
things you always should do is if you're
if you're me and a sea coaster you
should spend a little time praying and
talking to your pastors talking about
why it's important to throw your name
into an ever increasing hat and for me
the piece that overtook me was this
notion that America can do for anyone
what she's done for me can I have a
chance to restore hope create
opportunities and protect the America
that made me possible made in America is
my story and once I had peace about that
I decided I'm not running against a
field I'm running to be president of the
United States to make sure that the next
generation of the American dream makes
mine pale in comparison to what they're
able to accomplish so making sure that
we Remain the freest fairest land on
God's green earth is my objective and I
am so thankful that I have a the
blessing of running for president in the
only country where this is possible and
frankly John the truth of my life
disproves every single Lie from the pit
of Hell that we're hearing from the
radical left
all right Senator I won't give the full
announcement but we have a town hall
coming up with you and we very much look
forward to it thanks for agreeing to do
it uh great job on The View today and
thanks for coming on to share with us we
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else